if you're anything like me your night
goes something like this after an
exhausting day you brush your teeth get
into your Zelda theme pajamas snuggle up
in bed turn the lights off and then
nothing no not the good kind of nothing
the literally 10 seconds ago I felt like
I would die if I didn't get into my bed
and now I'm perfectly awake kind of
nothing so you try to squeeze your eyes
tighter or maybe I'm just not in a
comfortable position yeah that'll solve
it but no the clock ticks and you become
increasingly more aware of every waking
second of sleep time that you're losing
and how increasingly bad tomorrow will
be you could have just slept at school
or work it was so easy then but now in
the solitude of night all you have is
your deepest darkest thoughts and that
damn clock that oh my god it's been
three hours if this sounds familiar to
you then this video is for you because
we've compiled some of the best advice
and practices to increase your odds of
falling asleep in minutes and while
we're going to start off with the stuff
you should do before hitting your bed we
also have a technique used by the US
Navy to fall asleep in two minutes when
you're stuck there lying awake so let's
start with seven things you should do
before you sleep number one is to sleep
in a colder environment your thermal
environment especially surrounding your
head and body is perhaps the most
underappreciated factor determining not
only the ease with which you'll fall
asleep tonight but also your sleep
quality whether you're overheating
because of heavy blankets pajamas or
just a hot room it's been shown to
decrease slow-wave sleep and REM sleep
even just to initiate sleep your body
has to drop two to three degrees
Fahrenheit or 1.5 degrees Celsius and so
being colder actually helps bring your
temperature down faster it might shock
you but the recommended temperature is
around 65 degrees Fahrenheit or eighteen
point three degrees Celsius for your
room going to cold isn't great either
but it doesn't have the same disruptive
effects on falling asleep or your sleep
quality as a hot room does number two is
to take a hot shower or bath before bed
you might think being all warm and fuzzy
is what makes you sleep but it
actually kind of the opposite when
you're exposed to hot temperature the
body can't hold on to the heat and sends
blood to the surface of your skin giving
you that flushed red appearance once you
step out of the warmth the dilated blood
vessels radiate out the inner heat to
your environment and your core body
temperature plummets this triggers the
body and brain to think it's sleepytime
number three is to put away the clock
simply having the ability to look at and
see the time and find out how much you
haven't slept is not helpful and will
honestly only stress you out in fact
time monitoring is strongly linked to
stress and waking arousal for you should
minimize or avoid caffeine and nicotine
Coffee colas some tea and even chocolate
can take as long as eight hours to wear
out fully and nicotine is a stimulant so
avoid them too late in the day
it's also worth avoiding eating too
close to bed while some studies show
avoiding diets that are excessively
biased towards carbs will help it's
better to just avoid being too hungry or
too full before bed
number five exercising and being
physically tired can help you fall
asleep faster but working out two to
three hours before bed can keep you up
longer so earlier in the day is better
and same goes with naps actually they're
great but don't take them after 3 p.m.
or it'll be harder to fall asleep at
night number six is to make sure you're
actually relaxing before bed if you try
to sleep in your wired or on your brain
just won't be ready a relaxing activity
within the hour before bed like reading
is the perfect ritual to put you in the
right mindset and finally number seven
is to make sure you're getting sun
exposure during the day and minimizing
your light exposure during the evening
you've probably been told not to use
your screen before bed which is true but
it's equally as important to get natural
sunlight for at least 30 minutes a day
if you have problems falling asleep this
helps to condition your body's schedule
and trigger tiredness at the right times
so now that we've set up some conditions
for optimizing your experience of
falling asleep you're still awake in
fact maybe you've already done those
things in you're lying in bed right now
desperately looking up how to fall
asleep faster on YouTube which led you
to this very video
don't lie in which case you have broken
rule seven of not looking at your phone
but I'll forgive you if it was in pure
desperation I mean I won't complain
about the ex review but in all
seriousness if you're laying in bed
after all that there's a technique that
the Navy allegedly used that if
practiced can literally have you falling
asleep in two minutes no matter where
you are I say allegedly because the
studies are not publicly available but
they claim they were used on fighter
pilots who would often make avoidable
mistakes as a result of stress and
ultimately sleeplessness in fact they
were designed to allow them to fall
asleep even while sitting up and after
six weeks they claim that ninety six
percent of the pilots could fall asleep
in less than two minutes it goes like
this first you need to systematically
relax each part of your body take a deep
breath close your eyes and begin to
focus on your face picture every muscle
slowly relaxing if you need help squish
and squint your face first and then let
it relax breathe out as you feel your
cheeks tongue mouth and jaw relaxed even
imagining your eyes sinking into their
sockets then slowly make your way down
your body and do the same thing to each
muscle group tighten and then relax your
shoulders then arms from forearms to
fingers chest and legs and finally your
feet all while breathing deeply and
focusing on the relaxation once you've
gone through the whole body focus on
clearing your mind into a meditative
state as thoughts about your day or
images pop into your mind try not to
dwell on them and let them pass simply
thinking through motions can stimulate
your muscles to involuntarily contract
much like meditation
don't let the thoughts consume you try
to focus on breathing in and out or you
can visualize yourself in a common
location like on a warm summer's day in
a hammock swaying slowly back and forth
if you can't stop your thoughts they
suggest repeating don't think don't
think don't think for 10 seconds it may
sound silly or fairly simple but it's
the practice that makes perfect and
anecdotally online people have found it
to work after dedicating time to it but
the key like most things is to
consistent
a practice each night it won't be a
simple solution on your first night but
weeks in you'll be much more likely to
fall asleep instantly assuming you don't
have a sleep disorder or other condition
now there is one more suggestion that is
considered the single most important tip
to falling asleep immediately and if you
can't follow any others follow this go
to bed and wake up at the same time of
day no matter what even the weekends I
know it sucks but we're creatures of
habit and if you want to be able to fall
asleep immediately getting in a good
routine will set up your body to
literally work like clockwork and after
all that if you still can't fall asleep
don't lie awake in bed
studies show that not falling asleep for
an extended period of time causes
anxiety and only makes things worse so
just get up and do a relaxing or
slightly boring activity until you feel
sleepy thank you guys for watching we
played around with the animation style a
little bit in this video it's a little
longer so let us know in the comments
what you thought of it and we're gonna
make a playlist of a lot more sleep
videos over there because the common
themes to the very important make sure
you're subscribed for more and click
that bow oh yeah check them out not
matter of apparel you like develop you
want to see more of our videos and
otherwise we'll see you next time see
you later